FACE TEST.
THEY ARE THE ONES CLOSING THE
SCHOOLS.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
TONIGHT.
ALL OF THE PRESENTERS DID THEIR
BEST TO IGNORE THE VIOLENCE AND
THE DECAY OF ALL OF THE CHAOS IN
ALL OF THE AMERICAN CITIES.
IT DOESN’T TAKE A DETECTIVE TO
FIGURE OUT WHY, BECAUSE, IT’S A
PERFECT TIME FOR THE G.O.P. TO
START TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THIS.
MY NEXT GUEST IS WORK THING TO
DO JUST THAT.
IF SHE HAS GONE VIRAL FOR TAKING
HER MESSAGE TO THE STREETS OF
BALTIMORE.
>> YOU CARE ABOUT BLACK LIVES?
THE PEOPLE THAT RUN BALTIMORE,
DON’T.
I CAN PROVE IT, WALK WITH ME.
IF THEY DON’T WANT YOU SEEING
THIS.
I AM A KIM KLACIK, THIS IS
BALTIMORE, THE REAL BALTIMORE.
AT THIS IS A REALITY FOR BLACK
PEOPLE EVERY SINGLE DAY, CRUMBLY
INFRASTRUCTURE, ABANDON HOMES,
PROPERTY, AND CRIME.
THEY’VE BEEN RUN BY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY FOR 53 YEARS,
WHAT IS THE RESULT?
BALTIMORE IS ONE OF THE TOP FIVE
MOST DANGEROUS CITIES IN
AMERICA.
AT THE MURDER RATE IN BALTIMORE
IS TEN TIMES THE U.S. AVERAGE.
GO TO ANY BALTIMORE NEIGHBORHOOD
AND ASKED THIS QUESTION, DO YOU
WANT TO DEFUND THE POLICE?
>> NO.
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> I THINK IF WE DEFUND THE
POLICE, IT’S GOING TO BE WORSE.
I’M OPPOSED TO THAT.
>> WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO THAT
FOR?
WHY?
HOW DO YOU DEFUND YOUR CITY,
YOUR COMMUNITY, FAMILIES ARE
LOSING PEOPLE.
>> THEY THINK THEY CAN CONTROL
US FOREVER, THAT WE WON’T DEMAND
BETTER, AND THAT WE WILL KEEP
VOTING FOR THEM FOREVER.
DESPITE WHAT THEY’VE DONE FOR
OUR FAMILIES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES, ARE THEY RIGHT?
>> Laura: JOINING ME NOW IS A
WOMAN YOU JUST SAW, KIM KLACIK,
CONGRESSIONAL CANDIDATE FOR
MARYLAND’S SEVENTH DISTRICT.
KIMBERLY, THIS NOW HAS OVER
5 MILLION VIEWS ON YOUR TWITTER
PAGE.
WHAT HAS THE RESPONSE BEEN FROM
THE PEOPLE INVOLVED IN
BALTIMORE?
>> THINK YOU FIRST OF ALL FOR
HAVING ME, LORD.
WAS JUST SITTING HERE LAST
SUMMER TALKING ABOUT THE VIDEO
THAT WENT VIRAL, BECAUSE
PRESIDENT TRUMP RETREATED.
WERE TALKING ABOUT THE SAME
THING, THE SAME PROBLEM.
I’VE BEEN NOTICING, A LOT OF
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN COMMENTING,
SAYING, SHE IS NOT LYING ABOUT
WHAT’S GOING ON HERE.
I’M SO THANKFUL THAT SO MANY
PEOPLE TOOK NOTICE, AND THEY’VE
BEEN RETREATING IT, EVEN THE
PRESIDENT RETWEETED IT TODAY.
PEOPLE ARE REALLY THINKING, HEY,
YOU KNOW WHAT, IF WE VOTE
REPUBLICAN, COULD THINGS CHANGE?
I WANT TO GET AN OFFICE AND SHOW
PEOPLE THAT YOU HAVE A BETTER
QUALITY OF LIFE, IT IS POSSIBLE,
ESPECIALLY IF YOU VOTE
REPUBLICAN.
>> Laura: IT SEEMS LIKE THE
MESSAGE OF HOPE USED TO BE WHAT
THE DEMOCRATS STOOD FOR.
BACK IN 9092, HE WAS THE MAN FOR
HELP, HOPE AND CHANGE.
THE LAST FEW DAYS, THERE’S BEEN
A LOT OF DEPRESSING, DARK
FEAR-BASED MESSAGING.
I DIDN’T SEE A LOT OF HOPE FROM
EITHER DAY, FRANKLY.
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I SAW THE SPEECH THAT
MICHELLE OBAMA GAVE, AND SHE
TALKED ABOUT HOW EVEN SHE IS A
VICTIM, BEING BLACK IN AMERICA
FROM HER MANSION IN MARTHA’S
VINEYARD.
IT’S ALWAYS ABOUT VICTIMIZATION.
I KNOW FOR A FACT IN BALTIMORE
CITY, SO SHE WHERE I WAS IN
THOSE VIDEOS, BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF FEDERAL FUNDS WERE
SENT TO THAT AREA, AND HERE IT
IS IN 2020, IT HAS A MAKE IT TO
THE GROUND.
FROM WHAT I CAN SEE, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY LOVES TO
LEVERAGE THE URBAN STRUGGLES AND
ANNUALLY ASK FOR MORE FEDERAL
FUNDS, BUT THEN THEY DON’T
REMEDY THE PROBLEMS AND SAY,
THIS IS WHAT WERE GOING TO DO.
NO ONE FOLLOWS UP ON IT.
I THINK PEOPLE EXPECTED AT THIS
POINT.
I THINK NOW WERE AT A POINT
WHERE PEOPLE ARE SAYING, MAYBE I
WON’T VOTE DOWN BALLOT.
MAYBE I’LL LOOK AT OTHER
OPTIONS.
GOING THROUGH THE CITY, JUST
TALKING TO THE PEOPLE ABOUT WHAT
THE ISSUES ARE.
ASK THEM, WHY HAVEN’T YOU EVER
VOTED FOR REPUBLICAN OR
SOMETHING DIFFERENT?
A LOT OF PEOPLE WILL SAY, YOU’RE
THE FIRST REPUBLICAN I’VE EVER
MET.
WE HAVE TO STOP WRITING OFF THE
CITIES THAT WE THINK WE CAN’T
WIN AND REALLY GET IN THERE AND
ROLLER SLEEVES UP, AND LET THEM
KNOW THEIR OPTIONS.
>> Laura: YOU CAN’T WIN IF YOU
DON’T SHOW UP.
IN A VERY SIMPLE COMMERCIAL,
SIMPLY WORDED, AND BEAUTIFULLY
SHOT.
OF COURSE, YOU LOOK GREAT IN IT
AS WELL, WHICH ALWAYS HELPS.
IT WAS BEAUTIFULLY LAID OUT.
I’M CURIOUS, WHO HAD THE IDEA
FOR THE LAYOUT OF THE
COMMERCIAL?
JUST THE STYLISTIC LOOK OF IT?
>> LUCKILY THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON FOR
OVER A YEAR.
IF YOU GO TO MY YOUTUBE CHANNEL
YOU WILL SEE WHERE WE HAVE MANY
VIDEOS WE GO OUT AND INTERVIEW
PEOPLE, KIND OF LIKE THE MAN ON
THE STREET INTERVIEW STYLE.
I WOULD SHOW PEOPLE JUST EXACTLY
HOW BAD IT IS.
WE HAVE OVER 7,000 VACANT HOMES.
THERE AREN’T ANY CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES.
AS A MEMBER OF CONGRESS IN
NOVEMBER, I WANT TO BRING
OPPORTUNITIES TO THE AREA.
BALTIMORE CITY HAS THE SECOND
LARGEST PORT IN THE COUNTRY, WE
COULD UTILIZE THAT.
WE RELIED ON OTHER COUNTRIES FOR
PTE, WHY NOT BRING THAT
BILLION-DOLLAR MEDICAL
INDUSTRY BACK TO AMERICA, AND
RIGHT BACK THROUGH THE BALTIMORE
PORT?
>> HAVE YOU HEARD FROM
GOVERNOR HOGAN?
>> NOT YET.
WE ARE HOPING HE WILL REACH OUT.
WE’VE BEEN TRYING TO REACH HIM.
>> Laura: THE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR OF MARYLAND HAS NOT
REACHED OUT TO YOU AFTER THIS
VIDEO?
>> NOT YET.
>> Laura: HAS THE RNC REACHED
OUT TO YOU TO SPEAK?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THEY HAVE AND ASKED ME TO SPEAK,
BUT THEY DID REACH OUT AND
CONGRATULATE ME ON THE VIDEO AND
SAY THEY ARE THERE TO HELP.
>> Laura: KIMBERLY, YOU SHOULD
BE APPEARING AT THE RNC NEXT
WEEK.
I HOPE THEY ARE WATCHING,
BECAUSE IF THEY HAVEN’T FIGURED
THIS OUT YET, I DON’T KNOW WHAT
TO SAY.
KIMBERLY, BEST COMMERCIAL I’VE
SEEN IN, COULD BE TEN YEARS.